let me ask you about the war in Ukraine
oh yeah I got into plenty of trouble
about that too
you're you're just a man in a suit
talking on microphones and writing
brilliant articles there's also people
dying
fighting it's their land it's their
country it's their history this is true
for both Russia and Ukraine it's people
trying to ask they have many dragons and
they're asking themselves a question who
are we what is this what is the future
of this nation we thought
we are a great nation and I think both
countries say this and they say
well how do we become the great nation
we thought we are yeah and so what uh
first of all you got in trouble what
what's the the Dynamics of the trouble
and uh
regret no no I thought about it a lot I
laid out four reasons for the war and
then I was criticized in the Atlantic
for the argument was reduced to one
reason which was a caricature of the
reason
I gave a variety of reasons why the war
happened mismanagement on the part of
the West in relationship to Russia and
foreign policy over the last since the
wall fell
it's understandable because it's
extremely complex
hyper Reliance on Russia as a cardinal
source of energy provision for Europe in
the wake of idiot Environmental
globalist utopianism
um the expansionist Tendencies of Russia
that are analogous in some sense to the
Soviet Union Empire building and then
the last one which is the one I got in
trouble for which is Putin's belief
or willingness to manipulate his people
into believing that Russia is a salvific
force in the face of idiot Western
wokism and that's the one I got in
trouble for it's like while you're
justifying Putin it's like
it's not only it's not only the Russians
that think the West has lost its mind
the Eastern Europeans think so too and
do I know that it's like well I went to
15 Eastern European countries this this
spring and I talked to 300 political and
cultural leaders and you might say well
they were all conservatives it's like
actually no they weren't
most of them were conservatives because
it turns out that they're more willing
to talk to me but a good chunk of them
were
liberals by by any stretch of the
imagination and a fair number of them
were canceled progressives
well because you're very concerned about
um the culture wars that perhaps are a
signal of
um a possible
bad future for this country for this
part of the world that reason stands out
and
do you sort of looking back at four
reasons think it deserves to have a
place in one of the four oh because
absolutely because it is you know uh
well it's a bifurcated because I said
look Putin might believe this and I
actually think he does because I read a
bunch of Putin speeches and I have been
reading them for 15 years and my sense
of people generally and this was true of
Hitler it's like what did Hitler believe
well did you read what he wrote he just
did what he said he was going to do and
you might think well some people are so
tricky they have a whole body of
elaborated speech
that's completely separate from their
personality and their personality is
pursuing a different agenda and this
whole body of speech is nothing but a
front
it's like good luck finding someone not
sophisticated first of all if you say
things long enough you're going to
believe them that's a really interesting
and fascinating and important Point even
if you start out as a as a lie as a
propaganda I think Hitler's is an
example of somebody that I think really
quickly you start to believe the
propaganda well you've thought a lot
about AI systems it's like
don't you become what you practice
and the answer to that is well
absolutely we even know the neurology
it's like when you first formulate a
concept huge swaths of your cortex are
lit up so to speak but as you practice
that
first of all the right hemisphere stops
participating and then the the the laugh
participates less and less until you
build specialized machinery for exactly
that conceptual frame and then you start
to see it not just think it
and so if you're telling the same Lies
Over and Over who do you think you're
fooling think well I can withstand my
own lies
not if they're effective lies and if
they're effective enough to fool
millions of people and then they reflect
them back to you what makes you think
you're going to be able to withstand
that you aren't and so I do think Putin
believes
to the degree that he believes anything
I do believe that he thinks of himself
as a bulwark for
Christendom against the degeneration of
the West and that's that third way that
Dugan and Putin have been talking about
the philosopher Alexander Dugan and
Putin for 15 years now what that is is
very amorphous solzhnitzen thought the
Russians would have to re return to the
incremental development of Orthodox
Christianity to escape from the
Communist trap and to some degree that's
happened in Russia because there's been
a return to Orthodox Christianity now
you could say yeah but the Orthodox
church has just been co-opted by the
state and I would say there's some
evidence for that I've heard for example
that the
Metropolitan
owns now I don't know if this is true
owns five billion dollars worth of
personal property and I would say
there's a bit of a moral hazard in that
and it's possible that the Orthodox
church has been co-opted but there has
been somewhat of an orthodox Revival in
Russia and I don't think that's all bad
now even if Putin doesn't believe any of
this if he's just a psychopathic
manipulator and unfortunately
I don't think that's true
I've read his speeches it doesn't look
like it to me and he is by no means the
worst Russian leader of the last hundred
years
well there's quite a selection there
there certainly is but and I say that
knowing that
even if he doesn't believe it
he's convinced his people that it's true
and so we're stuck with uh we're stuck
with the claim in either case
and that's the point I was trying to
make in the article sometimes I'm
troubled by
people that explain things and I've a
lot of people reached out to me experts
telling me how I should feel
what I should think about Ukraine oh you
naive
Lex you're so naive you know here's how
it really is but then I get to see
people that lost their home I get to see
people on the Russian side who believe
they're I genuinely think that there's
some degree to which they have love in
their heart they they see themselves as
Heroes saving a land from uh from Nazis
how else would you motivate young men to
go fight it's just it's these humans
destroying not only their homes but
creating generational hate destroying
the possibility of Love towards each
other
they're they're basically creating hey
what I've heard a lot of is on February
24th this year
hate was born at a scale that region is
not seen
hate towards not Vladimir Putin hate
towards not the soldiers in Russia but
hates towards all Russians
hate that was last generations and then
you can you you could see an um
just the the pain there and then then
when all these experts talk about uh
um
Agriculture and energy and geopolitics
and yeah maybe like what you say with
with the
fighting the ideologies of the woke and
so on I just feel like it's missing
something deep
that war is not fought
about any of those things War started
and Wars diverted based on human beings
based on well here's here's Humanity
here's another
ugly thought since we haven't had enough
so far
we locked everything down for kovit
how much face-to-face communication was
there between the west and Vladimir
Putin how about none how about that was
the wrong amount
especially given that Europe was
completely dependent on Putin for its
energy supplies well not completely but
you know what I mean
materially and significantly so maybe
had to go talk to him once every six
months maybe he's in a bit of a bubble
probably and not just an information
bubble how all these experts tell me
about yeah no a human human
look one of the things I've really
learned there's a real emphasis on
Hospitality in the Old Testament
I just brought all these Scholars
together to talk about Exodus hey I have
this security team with me and they're
tough military guys but they're on board
for this Mission let's say
and so they went out of their way to be
hospitable to my academic guests they
laid out nice platters of meat and
cheese and crackers they spent all day
preparing this house I had rented so
that we could have a hospitable time
with these Scholars most of whom I
didn't know well but who said they would
come and spend eight days talking about
this book with me we rented some jet
skis we had a nice house we had fun and
we got to know each other and we got to
trust each other because we could see
that we could have some fun and that we
could let our hair down a bit we didn't
have to be on guard and that made the
talks way deeper and then
we found out we couldn't get through
Exodus in eight days and so
I had proposed very early on that we're
going to double the length and so I
pulled eight people out of their lives
for for eight days that's a that's not
an easy thing to do it's also quite
expensive and daily wire plus people
picked all that up and they said right
they said yes right away so we'd love to
do this again well why well partly
because it was intellectually it was
unbelievably engaging I learned so much
it'll take me like a year to digest it
if I can ever digest it and but they had
they had a really good time and so when
they were offered that combination of
intellectual challenge let's say in
Hospitality it was a no-brainer they
just said every one of them said if I
can do it in any way I will definitely
be there and this I went to Washington a
bunch of times
and the the culture of hospitality has
broken down in Washington
40 percent of congressmen sleep in their
offices they don't have Apartments their
family isn't there with them they don't
have social occasions with their fellow
Democrats or Republicans much less
across the table
and so and I tried to have some meetings
in Washington that were bilateral a
couple of times get young Republican
congressmen and Democrats together to
talk and as soon as they talk they think
oh
it was so interesting because one of the
lunches was about 15 people half
Democrats and half Republicans and all
I'd asked them to do was just spend
three minutes talk about why you decided
to become a congressman which is not a
job I would take by the way
he spent 25 hours a week fundraising on
the telephone
your family isn't there with you you
have to run for your re-election every
two years you're beholden to the party
apparatus
write your vilified constantly this is
not
you know people think well this is a job
for the privileged it's like yeah
you go and run for Congress and find out
how much fun it is and put your family
on the line and then have to beg for
your job every two years well your enemy
is the worst of your enemies are the and
the worst of your friends are viciously
hen pecking you
and so anyways we had them all sit
around the table said okay just say why
you
ran for congress it was so cool
especially for a Canadian because you
Americans you're so bloody theatrical
it's something to watch
it was like Mr Smith Goes to Washington
for every one of them it's like well
this country has given us so much where
families have been so so uh We've
benefited so much from our from our time
here we think this is a wonderful
country we really felt that we should
give back and the next one would talk
and it was like exactly the same story
and then it didn't matter if they were
Republican or Democrat you couldn't tell
the difference no one could and was it
genuine it's like well are you genuine
you think these people are worse than
you
first of all they're not
second of all they're probably better
All Things Considered it's not that easy
to become a congressman and I'm sure
there's some bad apples in the bunch but
by and large you walk away from your
meetings with these people and you think
pretty impressive they really are giving
a part of themselves in in the name of
service maybe over time they become
cynical and become jaded and won down by
the whole system but I think a lot of it
could you imagine that is healed I think
and I don't think I'm well I'm in part
naive but not fully that a lot of it is
healed through the power of conversation
just basic social interaction
I do think that the Batman the effects
of this pandemic by listening
listen just sitting there and it doesn't
have to be talking about the actual
issue it's actually humor and all those
kinds of things uh about personal
struggles all those kinds of things that
remind you that you're all just humans
yeah well the great leaders that I've
met because and I've met some now
they go listen to their constituents
it's not a policy discussion it's not an
ideology discussion they go say okay
what's what's your what's your life like
and what are your problems and
tell me about them and then they listen
and then they're struck by them and then
they gather up all that misery and they
bring it to the Congressional office or
to the Parliament and they think here's
what the people are crying out for and
the good leaders that's a leader leader
listens
so I talked to Jimmy Carr
about comedy
and he's sold out
stages worldwide on a tour being funny
that's hard he said comedy is the most
stand-up comedy
which is what I do in some real sense
it's a thing I do that it's most akin to
what I'm doing on my book tours I would
say it's the closest analog he said it's
the most dialogical Enterprise and I
thought well why what do you mean
because see it's just the monologue and
it's a prepared monologue I mean you
have to
interact dynamically with the audience
while you're telling your jokes and
you've got to get the timing right but
you have a body of jokes he said well
here's how you prepare the jokes
and I've been told this by other
comedians you go to 50 clubs before you
go on your tour
and you got some new material and you
think it's funny
and you go into a club and you lay out
your new material and people laugh at
some of it
and you pay attention
to what they laugh at and what they
don't laugh at so you subject yourself
to the Judgment of the crowd and you get
rid of everything that isn't funny
and if you do that enough even if you're
not that funny
the crowd will tell you what's funny so
you can imagine imagine you do 50 shows
and each is an hour long and you collect
two minutes of humor from each show so
you throw away 90 you throw away
two hours more than 98 of it it's like
two minutes per show
so you're not very funny at all you're
like funny two percent of the time you
aggregate that man you're a scream so so
that's what a leader does is that is
what leader does is goes out and he
Aggregates the misery you know and the
hopes
and then I do think that's revivifying
to someone who would otherwise be
cynical and jaded because then the
person can say to themselves
despite the inadequacies of the system
and my inadequacies
I'm
I'm gathering up the misery and and the
hope and I'm bringing it Forward where
it can be giving it a voice giving
that's right giving it a voice